the first results confirmed what most
people in the netherlands expected
mark rutter has done it again the dutch
prime minister's led his center-right
party to victory for a fourth time
in a general election
voters stability in a campaign that was
dominated by the coronavirus pandemic
with a country under a nighttime curfew
there were no victory parties
votes in the netherlands have given me
my party the dutch level party an
overwhelming
vote of confidence and it is humbling
it's also forcing us to do everything we
can
to make a success out of it voting was
spread over three days and special
polling stations were set up to allow
for social distancing
more than 16 000 people have died of
covid in the netherlands since the start
of the pandemic
far-right leader gert fielders conceded
that the health crisis had overshadowed
other
issues including immigration i share
that concerns about
health care and there was a lot of
problems about healthcare in the
netherlands as well
but they are also concerned about the
normal routine life you know not only
the economy
but also indeed islam or immigration
felder's party lost seats and slipped to
third place
behind the centrist d66 party led by
foreign trade minister sigrid karg
this analyst says it was one of the
election night's unexpected turns
which is a huge uh surprise and also
they this is way more than they had in
all the polls during the past months
and it's probably because their leaders
has been doing very well in all the
debates has been a big surprise this
campaign
so i think this has drawn a lot of
photos to d66 in these past few days
mark rutter has proved that he is a
political survivor he's been elected
despite some criticism
of his handling of the coronavirus
pandemic and two months ago he
and his whole government resigned over a
child benefit scandal
but in the end dutch voters chose
continuity
and gave him another chance natasha
butler
al jazeera amsterdam